Pour ne louper aucune vidéo,
abonnez-vouset activez la petite cloche !
Salut les Épicurieuses et les Épicurieux.
Je suis sûr quevous avez encore rêvé
de porter la couronne.
Je parle de la galette des Rois, bien sûr !
Maispourquoi les tire-t-on
au début du mois de janvier ?
La coutume existait déjà chez les romains.
Lorsdes repas organisés à l'occasion des Saturnales,
de grandes fêtes qui avaient lieu
au moment dusolstice d'hiver
et qui rassemblaient
maîtres et esclaves,
les convives choisissaient entre eux
unRoi.
Un roi éphémère, évidemment !
Il était tiré au sort
à l'issue d'une partie de dés
ou d'osselets.
Le gâteau dans lequel se cache une fève
n'apparaît quant à lui
que bien plus tard
auXIVème siècle.
A l'époque,
la fève
ressemble à ça.
C'est une véritable graine.
Mais pourquoi est-on passé
d'une graine naturelle ?
à un objet en porcelaine ?
Eh bien d'après la coutume,
il sembleque le roi
était obligé d'offrir à boire aux convives.
Certains,
un peu trop près de leurs sous
ouparce que la tablée était vraiment trop grande,
préféraient
avaler la fève plutôt que de débourser leur argent.
C'est donc
pour éviter cette tricherie
que les fèves en porcelaine
auraient remplacé les
fèves végétales.
La première aurait été cachée dans un gâteau en 1875,
en Allemagne.
Aujourd'hui,
vousconsommez chaque année
32 millions de galettes des Rois
au mois de janvier.
Une chance
pourles fabophiles :
les collectionneurs de fèves
et un regain de travail pour les dentistes
quandla dent du Roi
heurte trop violemment la fève.
Le seul
qui ne risque pas de se briser une dent
sur la fève,
c'est le président de la République française.
La galette des Rois est bien servie
chaque année à l'Elysée
mais aucune fève n'est cachée à l'intérieur
car dans notre république
onne peut pas être président
et roi en même temps.